et à Gaza et et ce weekend Emmanuel
Macron espéit réunir les dirigeants des
pays arabes les plus concernés par le
conflit mais cette rencontre n'a pas eu
lieu est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron s'est mis
à dos les pays arabes par ces positions
qui sont jugé
proisraël le président de la République
a eu plusieurs
déclarations qui qui ont manqué un peu
de cohérence d'abord la coalition
antihamas à l'instar de la coalition
anti
n'était pas la bienvenue elle a été très
mal perçue par les pays arabes d'autant
plus que le Hamas a un agenda
nationaliste il revendique un état il
revendique une place sur la géographie
israélo-palestinienne alors que DAEs
c'était une idéologie conquérrante et
destructrice donc il y a rien à voir
après le président pour corriger le tir
il a fâché Israël en parlant de cesser
le feu immédiat et puis il en a rajouté
une couche récemment il y a de jours
dans le golf bref on va revenir sur
cette phrase mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est encore un interlocuteur pour les
pays arabes Emmanuel Macron oou est-ce
que avec avec ce qui s'est passé depuis
le 7 octobre et ses positions il s'est
discrédité je dirais que la parole
présidentielle n'imprime plus dans la
région elle est contradictoire on sait
plus où la situé le en même temps ne ne
fonctionne pas je pense que on attend du
président de la République une vision un
plan de paix qui qui qui soit juste et
qui intègre les deux belligérants dans
une projection de paix régional au
Levant alors vous l'avez
dit